so
okay so my my center
is dependent upon the periphery
right and in this case what makes up the
periphery
my head and my feet hence our rule
if my head goes down at least one foot
has to come up this is a breaking
a center okay yes i still have a center
of gravity
but in terms of the spiraling rotating
cross
i'm not doing it in my body anymore okay
so my body stays locked
and i do that same thing this whole
thing is going to rotate
not on a circle has to go on a spiral
okay which means it must seek
some sort of traversing vector
it must have some sort of depth okay so
my body's going to go this way my body's
going to go that way
my body's not going to go this way okay
i think that's part of the problem
um is is why you have to disengage that
tail bone at the end
because there's no room for it you have
to get your legs back under you
you understand so you start you roll in
this way
and there's no there's no room for your
legs
so you're going to bend your knees a lot
and disengage the tailbone
this kind of thing but i don't do that
because
i have depth my legs are out my legs are
at home
you see how my legs are out watch my
legs again
lock my body lock my body boom
[Music]
okay let's try it again so again if i go
straight
then his forward roll any forward roll
kind of works
any forward over okay
but if i am trying to do the spiraling
cross geometry
it doesn't go on a circle it's going to
go on a spiral it's going to
seek depth
and then come around it's not going to
go straight it's not going to get
straight
i'm going to go straight it's one big
spiraling rock
he's feeling a young young
clap so to speak on your part his
projection
okay so we come around
and if he goes straight
i could do whatever
but when he does that spiral
i have to seek that depth
and a yang yin yin yang reconciliation
okay so instead of going here
and going
i would look at why did i feel your
elbow
and you felt my elbow too so we'll go
so you can see it slow so you can feel
it it's right there
you see but watch
me go around this cross
this cross right here watch watch it go
slower so you can feel it you feel that
there is there's a clash
i'm gonna go
you feel that yes
and as a result he can't he won't
project me
it just gets reconciled but i do lose my
balance
he goes i'm going around it
you watch my hips again
i'm reconciling
some clues to look is because he's not
projecting me
my shoulder is actually on the mat
before we even let go on the other one
your shoulders about
three feet four feet
you're watching the elbow energy be
reconciled
by the uke
but it's that same rotating cross
against the rotating cross okay
uh we're in i come here like this
and then you are now just stepping
around the guy and now
doing your regular forward rolls out
okay but you can't do that can you and
you're
not going why is that is your racism
yes my my leg is checking that leg out
you see
so we're gonna come over here like this
this leg is going that way
okay um
so that would not be it okay
uh when i get something else i pick
andrew because he's
he's bigger he's stronger than me okay
um if i establish a relationship to my
head
feet then i establish a center you see
the periphery is related to each other
then the center is established that
means
that's as heavy as i'm going to get okay
when i walk around or i break center
i'm very light is it okay okay
so uh we'll have you
try it and you'll feel what i'm talking
about is that she has my whole magazine
as my whole mass jacked her up okay
whereas if i would lose
and lose she can do it incrementally
but if i have my periphery related
and center this is very
and it starts to expose things in her
technique
now all i do is maintain center
let me see like that beat there it's not
marshall
that's where they do counters here and
stuff like that do you guys got that
okay so uh don't try to step around it
um
and you you can make sure that you are
always getting that leg
keep your circle that
just be calm be calm accept
um watch my face
[Music]
okay um let's try it again
okay so the question is what is the
growth stimulus training your uk
or you came at mine and you guys nailed
it it's way faster
and now the question is why is it faster
and you said we usually are having
energy right okay you're adding energy
to it so
diagnose how is the energy being added
to it
we're not just taking vagus growth we
are putting ourselves towards them
i would say no you are being accelerated
where is your acceleration point
set the elbow your elbows being
accelerated into the technique
how is that doable if you're resisting
with the elbow yeah you have a young
young
contact point there you get it so you'll
you'll feel
you'll feel it as we go right here
feel when it goes off here it's on
on and off and i just do that from the
start
this goes boom
so my roll is not accelerating
i don't get projected my roll
if we go slow slower
you see this here
is the yong yang this is the cross
there's the cross and it's going to
rotate
wait it's going to rotate i'm going to
not do my feet now
in trade positions
[Music]
okay you got it okay
so as you're doing your kimmy try to get
it off
by keeping your own rotating cross
inside your own body okay try it again